2g auch für kinder und jugendliche also
auch kinder und jugendliche werden
ausgesperrt sozusagen wenn sie nicht
geimpft sind alle über zwölf können sich
impfen lassen aber sie dürfen eben in
bayern nicht mehr alles das war die
berichterstattung auch von bild schon
gestern jetzt gibt es einen winzigen ein
mini rückzieher von markus söder den wir
noch mal kurz erklären müssen paul ja
der mini rückzieher betrifft engagement
im sportverein zum beispiel also kinder
und jugendliche dürfen dorthin ohne test
in dem moment und da gilt dann eine
ausnahme ist tatsächlich nur eine mini
ausnahme ansonsten will markus söder das
so durchziehen und man hat ihm angemerkt
dass er sich da auch weiterhin sehr auf
der richtigen seite wähnt und all
diejenigen die aus seiner sicht das war
ein wink richtung ampel das ganze
verharmlosen dass die dramatik nicht
sehen liegen aus sicht von marcos oder
falsch ohne impfung mehr dürfen sie zum
sport oder gemacht denn sie werden in
der schule regelmäßig geht das also die
tür aufhält dass er sagt die kinder auch
ab 12 bekommen natürlich regelmäßige
testungen dass in den schulen ohnehin
genommenen schulen ohnehin hier in
berlin beispielsweise dreimal in der
grundschritt immer interessant ist dass
er gerade diesen gesellschaftlichen
konflikte auch aufgemacht hat in dieser
pressekonferenz dass er auch ganz offen
diese starke polarisierung diese
trennung im moment in der gesellschaft
zwischen geimpften und ungeimpften auch
kritisch angesprochen hat aber befeuert
er das nicht gerade mit dieser
ausweitung noch mal der zweig regelung
markus söder befeuert diese spaltung wie
kein anderer politiker auf der einen
seite er hat sich immer als knallharte
als der härteste präsentiert und man
muss sagen er hat allerdings momentan
die schlechtesten werte also die
strategie die markus söder verfolgt
nämlich zu sagen wir greifen durch die
sieht man zumindest nicht bei den zahlen
auf der intensivstation bzw bei den
fällen und die sieht man auch nicht bei
der impfung auch bei allen werten ist
bayern im vergleich schlecht also muss
man sagen da es auch viel große klappe
am ende und jetzt sind es wieder die
kinder die kinder und jugendlichen nicht
so oft paul in dieser krise schon die
leidtragenden der wahn und werden ja
auch hier dieser sendung mit einer
mutter geredet die sagt ja was soll ich
jetzt machen also selbst wenn ich jetzt
sofort mit meiner teenager tochter dabei
ein teenager sohn zum impfen rennen
dauert er trotzdem noch um die fünf
wochen bis der oder diese wirklich an
dem sozialen leben teilnehmen ins kino
gehen darf oder in die disco gehen darf
also da setzten sie ja trotzdem fünf
wochen aus was ist das für ein signal
was man da setzt und wie groß ist auch
die befürchtung bei dir dass andere
bundesländer danach ziehen könnten ich
glaube das ist ein verheerendes signal
richtung kinder und jugendliche die ja
wirklich die schwächsten waren in dieser
pandemie in den vergangenen anderthalb
jahren die oft ihre freunde nicht sehen
konnten die schulen waren dicht also
genau diese problematik was dann im
sozialen umfeld passiert ja also was
sozusagen die folgeschäden auf der
anderen seite sind darüber redet markus
söder nicht stattdessen redet er darüber
dass er die hoffnung hat dass auch bald
noch jüngere kinder geimpft werden
können und verweist auf österreich und
sagt dass dort das eben möglich sagt er
verstünde gar nicht warum in deutschland
das nicht möglich sei also ich glaube er
macht da
eine neue spaltung
unbedingt verhindern will auf seiner
seite wieder auf ja also eher
emotionalisiert diese debatte seit
wochen seit monaten seit jahren immer
entscheidend mit und jetzt wundert er
sich dass es da eine gesellschaftliche
debatte gibt